hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
simone de beauvoir begins section two of
the ethics of ambiguity by
talking about childhood and adolescence
and the condition of people who are kept
within
what she calls the infantile world
and she begins with a reference to
descartes man's unhappiness is due to
his having first
been a child and then she says indeed
the unfortunate choices which most
men make can only be explained by the
fact that they've
taken place on the basis of childhood
and there's sort of a double
meaning to this given what she's saying
part of it is is that we
whether we realize it or not we have
imposed upon us
or we really nearly commit ourselves to
things
in childhood that that we should
probably reconsider
but the other is that people continue to
act
in relation to the world in the way
that that children do as adults
and that's not particularly helpful as
well
she talks about the child as living in a
serious world and indeed
very soon afterwards she will talk about
the serious person
as engaging in something that that has a
similar
attitude what does this mean to live in
a serious
world she tells us that the child
situation is characterized by finding
oneself cast into a universe they have
not helped to establish
which has been fashioned without them
which appears as an
absolute to which he can only submit in
his eyes human inventions words customs
values are given facts
as inevitable as the sky and the trees
this means the world in which he lives
is a serious world
since the characteristic of the spirit
of seriousness is to consider
values as ready made things and so
you know this is the human condition we
are all born as children into
families into cultures into
dynamics into situations that we
did not choose and many children do in
fact experience this as unfreedom
why do i have to go to school today i'll
give you another prime example of this
my uh one of my daughters said um
why do we have to take all these
standardized tests you know
they're really a waste of of time and
well that's the product of choices
of people in that particular state who
thought that standardized tests
are really something important worth
spending you know
scarce curriculum hours upon and so the
you know this we could talk about
example after example after example why
do we have to rise at this time
why do we have to go to school on these
days why is it pizza in the cafeteria
today you know
and we can go further and further and
further
that doesn't mean that the child's world
is one that
is totally lacking in freedom but they
are
taking the things that are there as if
they are
ready mate as if they are just facts of
life
as we say now i do have to point out
before we jump into the next discussion
that
de bevoir is not talking about every
case of
every child in the world you know when
we look at cases of children
who are put to labor very young or who
suffered horrific abuse i think that a
lot of what she's saying here
probably doesn't apply as as well
as it does to other you know types of
childhood
but it does cover an awful lot so she
goes on and she says
it doesn't mean that the child him or
herself
is serious on the contrary they're
allowed to play
what does that mean to expend their
existence
freely kids get away with you know
spending lots and lots of time doing
things
that you know have no practical purpose
whatsoever as a child i remember
being assigned chores getting the chores
done then going out to play and it might
be games with other people
it might be imagining ourselves as in
you know nights of old and getting
sticks and going after each other and
going on adventures
it could be pretending that we were in
the show battlestar galactica and you
know we used our imagination so much
that we dug trenches
in the ground and that was sitting in
the viper and then we'd load up you know
torpedoes as just logs that people had
cut
silly stuff right spending hours and
hours and hours
in coloring things so children get to do
that
and they passionately set up and pursue
goals you know prime example for for
myself again
was we would go to new construction
sites and take the
the uh various pallets and we would
build
forts out in the woods and we would
spend all this time discussing should
this wall go this way
or this way and what about you know
should we build another story on it
just stuff where an adult would come
along and be like what's the point of
all this and we
we thought there was a point so as human
beings we're always
engaged in some sort of goal setting
and the child gets to do that for
himself and and
as she says if the child fulfills this
experience in all tranquility
it's precisely because the domain open
to their subjectivity seems
insignificant and pure aisle they feel
themselves happily
irresponsible the real world is that of
adults where they're allowed only to
respect
and obey and we could also say there's
what about children who can test that
they're still contesting it within that
that framework
right so there's another key
aspect of this a moral aspect she says
that um the child takes you know parents
teachers others as divinities which they
vainly try to be and whose appearance
they would like to borrow before their
eyes rewards
punishments prizes words of praise or
blame
instill in them the conviction that
there exist a good and an evil which
like a sun and a moon
exist in ends in themselves so
one can be a good boy or a bad boy right
and it's measured
by this good and evil that exists out
there
they're not just human-created values
or human-oriented values they are things
that humans discover
and then tell you about and you know you
find out how to be a good boy or good
girl
through all of these promptings
and like she goes on to say normally the
child escapes the anguish of freedom
they can if they like be recalcitrant
lazy their whims and concerns
concern only them they do not weigh on
the earth
they cannot make a dent in the serene
order of a world which existed
before them so
then she goes on to discuss adults
adults who live
within an infantile world and here
we're looking at something that is is
you know we could say
it is normal in the sense that it's been
widespread
but it's not a normal part of human
development
in that it doesn't have to be that way
so she says
there are beings whose life slips by in
an infantile world because having been
kept
in a state of servitude and ignorance
they have no means of breaking the
ceiling
stretched over their head and she gives
a number of examples that we'll look at
in just a moment
she says like the child they can
exercise their freedom
but only within this universe which has
been set up before them
without them a little bit later on
she talks about people who
have no instruments whether it be in
thought or by astonishment or anger
which would permit them to attack the
civilization
that oppresses them and she says in this
case we have to judge them
only within this given situation and
you know it's possible in this situation
limited like every other one they
realize an assertion of their freedom
but they don't have a
possibility of liberation so they can't
actually uh
they don't have the access to human
freedom that others do
so servitude ignorance submission
these are things representing a world
that is imposed upon them
by other individuals but also by social
structures so what are some examples of
this
she talks about um you know a little bit
later on
the slave of the 18th century the
african slave
the islamic woman enclosed in a harem
not every single woman
but those who are you know put into
a leader's harem where that's it for
them that
that has become their world she talks
about
southern planters considering that the
africans who
docile submitted to their paternalism
were grown-up children
she says to the extent that they
respected the world of the whites the
situation of the black slaves was
exactly an infantile situation they were
not allowed
to progress they were kept in a
infantile
situation and if they didn't then they
were they were you know brutalized
until they would go along with it
she talks about the situation of women
in many civilizations they can
only submit to the laws the gods the
customs and truths created by
the males and then she says no she's
writing this you know in her time
even today in western countries among
women who have not had in their work an
apprenticeship of freedom
there are still many who take shelter in
the shadow of men
they adopt without discussion the
opinions and value values recognized by
their husband or their lover
that allows them to develop childish
qualities forbidden to adults because
they're
based on a feeling of irresponsibility
so this is the case for
for many people she goes on to say that
in some some cases you know this is
actually
something that a person is responsible
for so you could think of
you know the woman who decides that
she's going to be a kept person and just
go along with all the opinions of her
lover to keep the peace
in a way she's choosing that and and she
talks about choosing
or consenting she also talks about
complicity complicity with that very
power and thought structure she she says
that
[Music]
here we go in many cases this
thoughtlessness this gaity these
charming inventions imply a deep
complicity with the world of men
which they seem so graciously to be
contesting it is a mistake to be
astonished once the structure
seems to be in danger to see sensitive
ingenious and like-minded women show
themselves harder more bitter
and even more furious or cruel than
their masters and she says
it's then we discover the difference
which distinguishes them from an actual
child
the child situation is imposed on them
the person who is consenting
is in a certain way going along with it
because they're deriving
some sort of benefit from it and you
know we could say something similar
a similar critique arises within mary
wollstonecraft's vindication of the
rights of
women in her discussions of this
now she's also got this discussion about
adolescence
and she's not saying that adolescence is
normally the phase in which all this
happens
notice that she says it's rare for the
infantile world to maintain
itself beyond adolescence for some
children it could be before
adolescence that they're like this isn't
real
this is not the way things have to be
that happens for some
very young four five six years old
for many they go beyond at you know that
point and into adolescence and in
adolescence they're confronted with a
lot of different changes some of them
will still
you know decide they want to exist in
the world of childhood
but they are at that point choosing it
so she says
from childhood on flaws begin to be
revealed in this world
with astonishment revolt and disrespect
the child little by little asks
themselves why must i act that way what
good is it
and what will happen if i ask if i act
in another way
she says that in this time they are
discovering
their own subjectivity and they're also
discovering the subjectivity of others
they're discovering that the adults
don't actually know as much
as they thought that they did and
they're discovering that the
stereotypes that they rely upon often
turn out to be false
as well so like she says language
customs ethics values they have sources
in these contingent creatures what are
the contingent creatures
the current existing adults the adults
who came before
when these adults were merely children
and they realized that
you know things are not as
natural as grounded as necessary
as they've been made out to be or as
they thought that they were as they
bought into says the moment has come
when
they're going to be called upon to
participate in their operation
of these things his acts weigh upon the
earth as much as other people
he will have to choose and decide
so she tells us that there's there's two
sides to this um adolescence
is uh she she goes on a
um the collapsing of the serious world
is a deliverance
although he was irresponsible the child
felt himself defenseless before obscure
powers
whatever the joy of this liberation may
be it's not without great confusion
right so adolescence is a time she goes
on to say
of moral choice it is the moment of
moral choice freedom is revealed
he must decide upon his attitude in the
face of it
and so you know moral choice like she
says moral choice is free
and therefore unforeseeable the child
does not contain the man
he will become but it's always on the
basis of what he has been
that a person decides upon what they
want to be
there's also this realization of
responsibility which could be rejected
which could be
suppressed but you know you're gonna
identify
typical uh existentialist themes here
there is a conditionment of abandonment
being stuck in a world where now there
there really is no
longer anything that you can take refuge
in as a safe haven when it comes to
values
uh being unjustified having to come up
with the justifications oneself
and freedom freedom and responsibility
there's also a positive side to this as
well she talks about the joy
of existing that there can be
manifesting existence
as a happiness and the world as a source
of joy
but it's up to us to do that and that
does happen for many people
in adolescence that isn't an automatic
guaranteed thing that will happen
through that
so you know all these adults that are
existing
in infantile states so long as they
haven't been completely
stuck within a power structure and
meaning structure
that keeps them infantilized they will
have gone through adolescence
they may be at a great disadvantage you
know the position of women
versus men even in contemporary society
in many sectors of our society
is not exactly the same and and we can
talk about many other
uh types of of distinctions as well
but her point is we transition from a
world
of childhood in which we do have freedom
but it's not a freedom that that is a
freedom with responsibility
to a condition in which we as adults do
have to take responsibility
and existentialism provides us with the
framework
to do that
you